التطورات السياسيه في ليبيا ليست ببعيده
عن العسكريه وهنا لجنه اخرى ارقامها
مختلفه واطرافها ايضا لجنه خمسه زائد خمسه
تشكلت عام 2020 بموجب اتفاق في مؤتمر
برلين خمسه اعضاء عسكريين من المنطقه
الغربيه وخمسه عسكريين من الجيش الوطني
الليبي في المنطقه الشرقيه والهدف اعاده
الامن وتوحيد المؤسسه العسكريه التي
انقسمت عام 2014
منذ 2020 وحتى الان نجحت اللجنه في حل عدد
من الملفات ومنها التي كانت تغلقه
الميليشيات كما وضعت اللجنه خطه لترحيل
المرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب الا ان
الصراعات السياسيه حول هذا الامر عطلت
التنفيذ وتوقفت اعمال اللجنه قبل ان تعود
مره اخرى في يناير الماضي
[موسيقى]
ليست فقط اللجان في ليبيا متعدده الحكومات
كذلك هناك حكومتان الاولى حكومه حكومه
مكلفه من البرلمان برئاسه اسامه حماد كان
وزيرا للماليه قبل تكليفه بمهامة الحكومه
في مايو الماضي حيث صوت البرلمان على
ايقاف فتح بشاغه واحالته للتحقيق الحكومه
الثانيه هي حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه
عبد الحميد الدبيب الذي رفض طوال العام
الماضي تسليم السلطه للحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان وطبعا وجود حكومتين ادى لتفاقم
الوضع العسكري دعونا نلقي نظره على اماكن
السيطره في ليبيا الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان تفرض سيطرتها على شرق وجنوب
ليبيا حيث تمتد سيطرتها من اقصى الشرق في
الحدود الليبيه المصريه الى ما بعد المدخل
الغربي لسرت في الشمال بالاضافه الى اغلب
مناطق الجنوب وهي تعمل في اماكن سيطره
الجيش الوطنيه الليبي بقياده خليفه حفتر
اما طرابلس الواقعه في غرب ليبيا والقريبه
من الحدود مع تونس فهي تقع بالكامل تحت
سيطره القوات التابعه لحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه بقياده عبد الحميد الدبابه وهي
نقطه الصراع المشتعله حاليا في الساحل
الغربي الليبي هي مدينه الزاويه حيث اطلقت
حكومه الدبيبه عمليات بالمسيرات قالت انها
للقضاء على الخارجين عن القانون
تم دراسه مواقع خطوط التهريب وخطوط
التهريب البشره وتهريب البنزينه او دخول
الكوكايين والهيروين والمخدرات بجميع
انواعها
وتم الحقيقه
تحديدها بتحديد دقيق يجولي يجولي
العمليات يعني طبعا العمليات كمرحله اولى
عمليات جويه ونحب نقول لكم يا ليبين انقول
لكم في اللي يقولوا من دوله هدي ولا من
دوله هدي هذه الطيارات ملك للشعب الليبي
اللي انتم كلكم تملكوا هذه الطياره من
يوجهونا هذه الطائرات المهمه والحديثه هم
ليبيين تم تدريبهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات